[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look of course on
what's on the front pages time then to
see what is making the headlines with
the associate editor of the daily mirror
kevin mcguire and the consultant editor
of the daily mail andrew pearce both of
you with us until just before midnight
so let's see what's on the front pages
then starting with the i the high court
ruling criticizing the government for
discharging covert patients to care
homes during the pandemic makes the lead
for that paper the headline 20 warnings
missed to stop covert slaughter in care
homes
meanwhile porn mp exposed that's the
front of the metro which reports that an
unnamed conservative mp allegedly
watched pornography on his mobile phone
in the commons chamber a number of
female colleagues have complained
same story for the daily mirror the
headline tori's pawn shame in commons
and the daily express also has that as
its main story as you can see caught
watching porn in the commons
the telegraph says that the chancellor
is threatening a windfall tax on energy
companies if they fail to invest more in
the uk to support the economy at a time
of crisis
the financial times says that the price
of gas in europe has risen by another 10
after russia's decision to turn off
supplies to poland and bulgaria
the sun carries an announcement from
world boxing champion tyson fury that he
is finally retiring
and the start says scientists are
worried that the planet is under threat
because people are using too much toilet
roll
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us so let's uh bring in our guests
then kevin mcguire and andrew pearce
welcome to both of you with the news on
a number of newspapers
these allegations about a member of
parliament andrew watching pornography
on his mobile phone um your reaction
well what a horrible sleaze bag that's
the obvious reaction and it's disgusting
uh
i've always had reservations about how
easy it is to
access porn but the idea that a
parliamentarian paid whatever 84 000
pounds a year is in the commons chamber
while women mps are around him gazing at
porn we think he's done it more than
once we think he might have done it in a
select committee as well and at least
one woman mp tried to film him looking
at the pawn i mean shameless uh
he's going to be investigated whoever it
is
by the independent
authorities parliamentary authorities in
the house i think he'll ha he'll have to
be suspended when that inquiry is
completed and frankly i think the tory
party uh are gonna have to kick him out
we don't wanna mp like that in
parliament don't anyone in parliament
behaving like that whether they're an mp
member of staff you
watching porn you shouldn't be watching
porn in the workplace particularly in
the hallowed commons chamber for god's
sake is nothing sacred
yes and only people who have witnessed
the situation are able to make a
complaint to this body uh this
independent complaints and grievance
system which is you know going to be now
investigating it chief was going to look
into it clearly not now does it mean
it's all going to be a slow and
protracted uh process um kevin and and
the timing of this could not be worse
no i couldn't uh uh and aaron it's it's
utterly jaw-dropping and gobsmacking and
you you think you think you've heard and
seen it all yeah like andrew i can trace
back covering politics to the late 1980s
in the era of thatcher and then
this comes along you gotta believe there
were two mps made a complaint two women
mps who say they saw it so that's
corroboration um i can't see why chris
heaton harris the chief whip doesn't
launch his own investigation and if you
know if he knows who it is he's got the
name from the from these two to uh women
mps conservative mps about their
colleague that immediately suspend the
whip from uh the person unless they come
up with an incredibly um good
explanation which i'm not sure what it
could be but as you as you say it's
about time for the conservative party
because as the my own paper the daily
mirror uh does it call it um the new
sleaze uh
party
now you've got a wakefield by-election
coming up because the conservative mp
imran khan
was convicted of sexually abusing
a young
man you've got another tory mp who's
under investigation after a picture
appeared of him uh with what
was said to be
cocaine and a woman made allegations
against him which he strenuously denies
then you've got 56 mps across all
parties labour has its problem too uh
that have had complaints about sexual
harassment and abuse made against some
three were reported by the sunday times
to be
uh cabinet ministers interests of
fairness two are also said to be members
of the uh kyostomers uh labor from ben
schertin then you chuck in parties and
you begin to get that feel of what
happened to john major's government uh
the back basics it all just begins to
feel a bit sleazy and sordid and begins
to fall apart you chuck in the crucial
foster living crisis
and it's a very very toxic
mix electorally
and just um very quickly on the process
that we're seeing and andrea littleton
was saying today that in order to
protect the claimants the process in the
commons is supposed to be secret so this
leaking of 56 mps being investigated or
however it came out that should not be
happening because then it stops people
coming forward i don't know how open you
expect this to be andrew you know
whether these the names will eventually
come out or or not or or they should not
well
i mean that the whole point is that
people are supposed to be given
anonymity while they're being
investigated because um a lot of these
complaints we hope won't be upheld uh
but if they are upheld then of course
they'll be named but it but it's
parliament the place is it leaks like a
sieve uh there's already lots of people
uh think they know the name of this
conservative mp obviously i'm not going
to say who you think it is on the
program tonight but i would be amazed if
the name isn't out in 24 hours and
frankly uh as the this the name was
discussed a meeting where i think there
were 14 winning tory mps with the chief
whip of course it's going to get out and
why shouldn't it
okay
the name the name is out there we can't
use it unless you have absolute
cast iron
certainty for legal reasons unfairness
that it is him
but i'd like the name to be out there so
we can get a public explanation
otherwise
this mp can be playing a role in the
house of commons and public life
while they're
accused by two of their own colleagues
don't remember this it's not it's not
this is not the opposition party's going
for the government this is two
conservative women one said by my own
paper the daily mirror to be a minister
so what what is this mp going to be up
to in the meantime we saw that imran
khan wakefield was on a home office
panel looking into child sex abuse while
he was under police caution that should
not happen and it certainly shouldn't
happen again
okay uh interesting we will uh we will
keep an eye on that obviously let's move
on to the other big news of today or one
of the one of the big news which is uh
what happened uh in the courts the
government policies on discharging um
older people hospital patients into care
homes was deemed to be
unlawful and this you know opens up all
sorts of potential claims andrew we
await the inquiry it will certainly feed
into that as well
yeah
the high court said it wasn't only
unlawful it said the decision to um put
people out of hospitals without testing
them for covering into care homes was
also irrational putting it brutally
crudely um it was a bit like putting a
fox in a chicken coop people by
definitioning care homes are often
frailer and more vulnerable my newspaper
was campaigning about this right at the
off saying this can't be a good thing to
do it isn't right we we know that there
were there were various warnings about
the fact people could have coveted
without any symptoms but
up to 20 000 people died in care homes
how many of those now died as a result
of this
mad irrational as the court says
decision to put people out of hospitals
into cairns that being tested there will
be a mass of compensation claims quite
right too um but that doesn't bring
these people back and of course we have
to remember what matt hancock the health
secretary said he said if the worst
effect of something like we're putting a
protective arm around all the care homes
well no he wasn't and this is a man
who's just announced he's writing a book
but called pandemic diaries i don't know
how he's got the nerve yeah and they
also said at the time that they were
testing
on release from hospital which was also
not the case either there was no
secondary test for those who were in
hospital i mean i guess they watched
other countries uh saw the pressure on
health services there and recognized
that actually the last thing you need in
hospitals of with full of covid patients
was actually vulnerable people so where
else should they have gone you know what
what else could have been done or was it
simply that the eye was not on the ball
that the testing system wasn't in place
and the ppe hadn't been ordered either
but you're you're right uh
hospitals of our very nature have a lot
of vulnerable people soda care care
homes i understand get get out the el
get out the elderly vulnerable who can
into that care sector but the whole crew
at the crux of it is was no protective
ring they were sending infected people
into care home because they didn't test
properly and we were misled
we were misled by ministers claim
claiming testing was going on when it
wasn't
and the
uh eye picks up 20 missed uh
opportunities here the alarm bells were
ringing andrew is quite right the male
uh campaigned on it very very well i
recall at the time the daily mirror did
two
so
matt hancock as he as andrew says he's
right in this book i mean look it's
he wants a he wants a comeback he's
planning his own comeback this is why
there should be no comeback by matt
hancock but the prime minister has
questions to to answer to and you
understand why he wants to delay
the inquiry until after the general
election because they're going to be
incredibly searching questions asked and
the mistakes are going to be
exposed and
the government gets huge credit and
deserves it over the vaccination program
but a lot of people died needlessly
because of mistakes okay we're going to
talk about russia and gas after the
break but i do want to touch on front
page of the telegraph which is sunac
warning of a windfall tax would you
believe on energy firms which is clearly
what labour has been pushing for for
some time
yeah he was prodded on this on mumsnet i
don't think his heart's in it but what's
it what's interesting he is he's is he
sort of gone down the road of the
principal if he thinks energy companies
aren't supporting the economy but
dominic raj the justice secretary had
said the idea would be disastrous and uh
boris johnson said it would be a tax on
business so you can see the government
is pulling and looking in different uh
directions or all other wars andrew
quickly on that
i don't think that wish you soon that's
got any intention of bringing a winful
tax uh i think it would be a very
popular policy actually i mean there's
all sorts of reasons why i might not
support it but it would be popular but i
don't think he's going to say i think he
was just trapped by mumsnet very clever
organization he's not going to do it and
there's no support that i'm aware of in
the cabinet for it anyway okay plenty
more still to come including as i said
the story on the ft's front page which
says that gas prices are soaring as
russia turns off their taps to poland
and bulgaria discussing that in just a
moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now the associate
editor of the daily mirror kevin mcguire
and the consultant editor of the daily
mail andrew pearce welcome back to both
of you um kevin let's go to the ft shall
we uh gas prices soaring not surprising
i guess after what happened to poland
and bulgaria in terms of their russian
gas imports
no that's right they've their supplies
have been corrupt because they won't pay
in rubles which uh vladimir putin
decreed must be the case uh to try and
protect his currency which has just been
hammered by by sanctions interestingly
he's not taking the same line with
germany which buys a lot more gas
from uh
russia because presumably
he needs the euros that he gets in
return in germany gets the gas and it's
where there is this dependency across
the european union
which is accusing uh putin of trying to
blackmail [ __ ] reserves in wonderland
saying that well
well of course
there's a war on and there are economic
tactics as well as uh as well as
military but what it will mean for
consumers in the uk of course is world
prices soared 20 percent uh
the rise fell down at 10 percent but
nevertheless
world prices go up that means we will
face higher bills uh here the caps
already gone for households from 1400 to
2000 a year could go 2600
in october um no protection for business
users who are getting absolutely whacked
andrew your paper's just in let's have a
look at that shall we um which is that
the police uh have opened the door to a
full probe into claims that secure
stammer broke lockdown rules when he was
filmed drinking with party officials um
a 43 second video clip has emerged of
him in the office of mary foy labour mp
for the city of durham on april the 30th
last year and this is durham
constabulary saying it would consider a
request from tory mp richard holden to
review a controversial decision which
cleared the labour leader and this um i
guess is after senior conservatives
suggested this some hypocrisy in the way
that the police are handling the party
gate claims tell us more
yeah so richard holden is a local mp up
in durham he's he wrote to the chief
constable uh highlighting various parts
of their their rules and regulations
about covid uh and he said there is a an
inherent contradiction in how they
managed to take no further action
against starmah starmer of course was up
there campaigning for and during a
by-election it's not his home like down
the street is boris johnson's home he is
filmed
having a drink with colleagues uh he
says it's just that now the police said
the chief concert is saying he's gone
back to the detectives who took the
decision that there should be no further
action to ask them how they arrived at
that decision so potentially he's
opening the door to the whole matter
being reinvestigated now that would make
the tories fur with pleasure because
kirstama in my view has been banging on
too much about partygate and we know uh
from
tension in the shadow cabinet that at
the um uh the former the leveling up the
shadow leveling up secretary lisa nandy
has made that point too in a a
disagreement in shannon cabinet but um
kirsten has invested so much of his
whole attack on the government on the
fact boris johnson broke the rules also
whether he lied about the rules and i
know when suggesting kierstahl has lied
but if the police were to reinvestigate
until he did break the rules that would
be a huge setback for labour okay we
were going to do the daily start not
about the uh the loo rolls running out
but the methane masks for cows run out
of time sadly to do that kevin mcguire
andrew pearce thank you both very much
indeed